In the 1970s, Portugal’s Carnation Revolution kicked
off a “global wave of democratization”
as people across the world demanded democracy from their governments.
Throughout the rest of the 20th century,
democracy continued to grow in popularity and legitimacy.
Even the most powerful autocracies like China
and Russia adopted more “democratic rhetoric.”
Yet, events in the 21st century have raised concerns about democratic backsliding
or the gradual shift away from democracy towards authoritarianism.
Although the numbers of total elections has been
increasing since the mid-20th century,
the line has plateaued and could be slowly declining.
A new review in Science evaluates democratic backsliding at the global level
by examining the conditions that pave the way for backsliding
and how international support for democracy has changed.
It spotlights “democracy scores” based on
how well a country conducts fair elections, protects basic freedoms,
and holds elected leaders accountable.
1976 marked the “beginning of the most recent wave of democratization.”
By 1989, countries in Latin America had transitioned
from military rule to democracies.
At the turn of the 21st century, the same clustering effect
occurred in Eastern Europe and sub-Saharan Africa.
But in 2019, democracy scores across the globe went down.
Concerns about backsliding are especially prominent
in countries experiencing nationalist movements,
declining trust in government institutions,
rising income inequality,
and populism — an ideology that pits “pure people”
against the “self-serving elite.”
All pose a threat to democratic governance.
A decline in Western support for democracy
has intensified these challenges.
Support has taken a bigger tumble within the
last four years than the previous forty.
Without international support, citizen movements are more
likely to be suppressed by their local and national governments.
This makes it more challenging to hold leaders
accountable for acts against democracy,
such as stealing elections or limiting individual rights.
Hong Kong’s recent pro-democracy
protests provide a unique example.
In 2019, China rolled out a new national security law
that undermined Hong Kong’s autonomous status.
The study says that international support
for Hong Kong was underwhelming.
And it suggests that if the protests had taken place just three years earlier,
they would have been met with more
powerful international support.
Democratic backsliding presents a
daunting reality in the years to come.